that is los angeles and we showed you a
couple of days ago the images of uh the
the burglars or robbers let's say
because they had sledgehammers they
knocked out the plate glass window at a
beverly hills
jewelry store right there they stole
between three and five thousand dollars
worth of expensive jewelry in the middle
of daylight absolutely and by the time
the owner came out the guy he the owner
was coming out with his gun uh they'd
already
jumped into a stolen car this is such a
problem and think about it la is a very
showy town if you've got a nice rolex
watch or something like that you're
going to wear it well maybe you
shouldn't because the cops say you will
be a target well you know you look at
this video we walk by jewelry stores
after they close they take out all the
jewelry right behind us is the diamond
district they take yes they empty the
cases they empty the windows because
they don't expect someone to do this in
the middle of the daylight
so here's what's going on the lapd is
hamstrung by these idiotic this idiotic
mayor i guess they believe in
distribution of wealth
says this over the last year there's
been a marked increase of armed
robberies involving victims wearing
expensive jewelry so here's a warning to
them if it's visible it can be a target
so you know that expensive jewelry leave
it where it belongs in the safe in your
house that's exactly why you bought it
you don't want to be able to wear it and
have someone steal it from you robberies
are up 18 robbers with a firearm they're
up 44 in that area if you read the
article this says the victims are being
targeted based on high-end jewelry and
high-end cars they'll follow these
victims home and target them one victim
was pistol whipped and the other had
their rolex and their phones stolen at
gunpoint
talks about how another one broke talks
about the jewelry store someone was
driving an expensive car and they
followed that person home and stole 3
600
so the the lapd now has a follow home
unit to follow some of these people who
might be following some of the people
who are going to try to hit somebody
over the head to steal their fans and
the way it's working is organized crime
is hiring these guys to smash these
windows they get the stuff and they sell
it on any site they want because crime
is okay uh in los angeles finally in new
york they're wising up and prosecuting
everything even for people that jump in
the turnstiles that's the new message
hopefully they'll get the message on the
west coast because they are destroying
that state you grew up here but remember
when we were growing up our my parents
always said if you go to new york don't
wear any jewelry put your money in a
money yes buy a pocketbook that has a
zipper so that they can't reach in there
and now we're back to that in l.a we are
yeah travel with the biggest strongest
guy in your class a lot of people don't
feel safe that's one of the reasons why
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now